what's going on there reject nation
we're gonna watch today disney's tangled
yeah this has been requested ever since
i covered in kanto
i know a lot of people are like greg
don't you normally have a lady guest
with you well all the ladies have seen
it
except john that's right man the sexiest
lady of them all hasn't seen it i'm
gonna be completely honest with you guys
i
don't know if i've seen this i have i
have no idea if i've actually seen some
of it or any of it i try to recall and
i'm like i don't know anything so i'm
going to assume that this is my first
time watching this movie to be totally
honest uh but yeah here we are uh if you
guys can leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
when we get another reaction up here on
the channel that you might enjoy full
length reaction watch along where you
sync up with your own copy or over at
our patreon page thank you to all become
super sexy rejects by checking out all
we got to offer got plenty of things
over there and thanks to the team at
prepper for helping us edit down these
reaction highlights lastly thank you to
storyblocks for sponsoring this video
let's see what's the big hype about this
film
this is the story of a girl named
rapunzel once upon a time a single drop
of sunlight fell from the heavens it had
the ability to heal the sick and injured
oh you see that old woman over there you
might want to remember her she's hot
check hot old lady and the queen well
she was about to have a baby but she got
sick she was running out of time and
that's when people usually start to look
for a miracle or in this case a magic
golden flower
you see instead of sharing the sun's
gift this woman mother gothel hoarded
its healing power and used it to keep
herself young for hundreds of years
mother gothel all she had to do
was sing a special song
bring back what once was mine
all right you get the gist she sings to
which she turns young creepy right she
is a hot old lady
so conflicted right now
the magic of the golden flower
healed the queen a healthy baby girl a
princess was born beautiful golden hair
i'll give you a hint
that's rapunzel
it's not a hint that's the answer
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
stole the child and just like that
gone
so you can't cut any of her hair in a
hidden tower
gothel raised the child as her own
[Music]
i had a horror movie based off of
something like this but the walls of
that tower could not hide everything
each year on her birthday the king and
queen released thousands of lanterns
into the sky never seen a terrifying
concept set up so sweetly before
let me suck on your life for us but it's
fun i'm gonna kidnap you
well i guess pascal's not hiding out
here
[Laughter]
7 am the usual morning line up start on
the chores and sweep to the floor's all
clear
[Music]
yeah
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
you're actually really productive man
yeah you got everything you need here
why do you ever want to leave you're
getting a lot done be a shutdown
[Music]
oh she thinks it's just some like
magical thing
wow
i could get used to a view like this
come on hold on i'm used to it
hay fever
yeah huh
what wait bad thief this is a very big
day pascal finally gonna do it i'm gonna
ask her
i'm not getting any younger down here
coming mother
and i i would like to be right now
[Music]
i feel like that would hurt her still
how you managed to do that every single
day without fail it looks absolutely
exhausting darling oh
it's nothing then i don't know why it
takes so long
[Laughter]
you are a great mother figure
it's my birthday
i distinctly remember your birthday was
last year
i want to see the floating lights you
know why we stay up in this tower to
keep you safe and sound yeah guess i
always knew this day was coming i knew
that soon you'd want to leave the mast
soon but not yet
trust me pet mother
knows this
yeah mother knows best one way or
another something will go wrong i swear
poison ivy quicksand cannibals and
snakes off the plane yes
then with pointy teeth and stop no more
you'll just upset me mother's right here
skip the drama stay
[Music]
get that grit plus i believe getting
kind of chubby yikes you're fat rapunzel
don't ever ask to leave this tower yes
mother i love you very much dear
clearly
i'll see you in a bit my flower
i'll be here
i don't know the rapunzel story
i know the very very basics she's so
cruel
no no no no no this is bad this is very
very bad this is really bad they just
can't get my nose right
who cares well it's easy for you to say
you guys look amazing the stabbington
brothers
fred and george stabbington
okay give me a boost and i'll pull you
up
give us the satchel first what
give me the whip i'll throw you the idol
i can't believe that after all we've
been through together you don't trust me
i i don't even trust you
i don't even know you and i don't trust
you
[Music]
now help us up pretty boy sorry my hands
are full what that's why they don't
trust you yeah
retrieve that satchel in any course sir
seemed like you were better off at the
dead end yeah you already jumped right
into the lights
[Music]
nice work man come on fleabag forward
no
no
huh
[Applause]
oh my god
yo
this is an incredibly well trained horse
[Music]
[Music]
that horse can withstand anything yeah
sharp on your feet horse
on your hooves
[Music]
someone turning 18 in there
i smell a birthday party
alone at last
you can't go to the outside the
outside's coming to you
imagine if it was one of the stabbington
brothers
you have the same reaction
double tap
i like your style rapunzel
oh
those are gonna
turn purple and fall off so i get it
it's about the cycle of abuse repeating
itself she's getting kidnapped taking
hostas now she does it to someone else
yeah she's recreating
it
like a glass
slipper have a big surprise i'm going to
make hazelnut soup for dinner surprise
there's something i want to tell you oh
rapunzel you know i hate leaving you
after a fight especially when i've done
absolutely nothing wrong
you are not leaving this tower
ever the frying pan rapunzel
i know what i want for my birthday now
and what is that
the paint made from the white shells you
once brought me you're sure you'll be
all right on your own i know i'm safe as
long as i'm here
i've packed you six apples for three
days worth of a trip and a hunk of bread
ration it out
i love her hair is like a superpower
who are you and how did you find me i
know not who you are nor how i came to
find you
but may i just say hi
oh my man
[Music]
oh no where is my satchel i've hidden it
somewhere you'll never find it it's in
that pot isn't it
take me to these lanterns and return me
home safely and only then will i return
your satchel to you just enough time to
fall in love
this is kind of an off day for me this
doesn't normally happen
fine i'll take you to see the lanterns
really
ah
oops it's okay it worked on me that was
an innuendo you think she'd be more
subject to the smolder i know i mean
having literally no suitors for 18 years
look at it all so big do i even dare
here i go
[Music]
if i take one step further
further from the shire that i've ever
featured
[Laughter]
[Music]
and finally
[Music]
you're getting your hair so dirty right
now
got to be so many bugs and twigs in
there
i can't believe i did that
mother would be so furious
that's okay i mean what she doesn't know
won't kill her right
oh my gosh
[Laughter]
i am a horrible daughter i'm
[Laughter]
would this break her heart and crush
your soul of course but you've just got
to do it
that is
that's growing up
[Laughter]
another different
nose yeah hide the nose the faces on
this horse
[Music]
[Laughter]
a palace horse where's your rider
rapunzel
rapunzel
oh shoot
rapunzel
oh no
god rapunzel you suck at hiding stuff
ah there it is the snuggly duckling
your finest table please
you don't look so good blondie maybe we
should get you home call it a day this
is a five-star joint after all and if
you can't handle this place well maybe
you should be back in your tower
what was this you oh now they're just
being mean oh it's him all right
i'm broke
get back
we can work this out
[Applause]
oh not the nose not the nose not the
nose
i'm i'm malicious mean and scary despite
my evil look and my temper and my hook
i've always yearned to be a concert
pianist
yep i'd rather be called deadly for my
killer show tuned medley
[Music]
that voice is the one that's bothering
me
i probably garrett's killer souls little
puppy and vladimir collects ceramic
unicorns
live your best life lad
just want to see these lanterns every
passing hour i'm so glad i left my tower
oh no
[Music]
where's ryder where is he
backstabbington brothers
go
live your dream i will
your dream stinks i was talking to her
thanks for everything
oh
this dream came true this is the man
you're looking for you got me sir
there's no sign of ryder
maximus
you play for the wrong team maximus
[Music]
a passage
come on man let's go
that horse is as smart as an elephant
we'll go get the crown
way to go fred and george
[Music]
who's that they don't like me
here
[Music]
such a swashbuckling vibe
oh
mama i have got to get me one of these
[Music]
you should know that this is the
strangest thing i've ever done
[Music]
that horse is relentless
cool
do it legolas
wow
that horse is gonna be surfing
gotta save the pan
you're awfully reliant on that pan
without the pen they'd be dead already
it's no use
i can't see anything
hey there's no point
it's pitch black down there sing the
song
i'm so sorry flynn
eugene
what
my real name is eugene fitzherbert
gesente
i have
magic
when i sing
i didn't even think about it
[Music]
[Music]
how's the glow lasting for so long
great question maybe she's singing in
her head her hair glows we're live
i'm alive i didn't see that coming
eugene they're actually glows eugene why
does her hair glow eugene what
perhaps you want to stop acting like
wild dogs and think for a moment
i was going to offer you something worth
1000 crowns enjoy your crown well now
they're gonna want to know you set them
up to ask that
once
[Music]
that's right
yeah man
she doesn't realize what she's singing
about
she can get her parents back now mother
says when i was a baby people tried to
cut it once it's cut it turns brown and
loses its power that's why
i never left and you never left that
tower but the gift's not even being used
a book i used to read every night to all
the younger kids the tales of flenigan
ryder you can't tell anyone about this
it could ruin my whole reputation [ __ ]
i i should i should get some more
firewood for the record i like eugene
fitzherbert much better than flynn rider
then you'd be the first but thank you
i like the name ryder better but if he
could have the personality of eugene
that would be the best i thought he'd
never leave mother
hello dear how did you find me oh it was
easy really i just listened for the
sound of complete and utter betrayal and
followed that
i think he likes me
likes you please rapunzel that's
demented what's to like
look at you you'll think that he's
impressed
don't be a dummy
come with mummy
mother
no mother no no go ahead then give him
this trust me my dear that's how fast
you leave go and put him to the test
[Music]
good luck
oh
well i hope you're here to apologize
[Music]
[Laughter]
easy
now sit
sit
what now drop the boot
i serve off camera
are you all tired from chasing this bad
man all over the place
excuse me
nobody appreciates you do they
do they
oh come on he's a bad horse oh he's
nothing but a big he's like the greatest
horses ever
horse efforts
i need you not to get him arrested
just for 24 hours and then you can chase
each other to your heart's content okay
oh yeah
kill a man easily
probably ruptured a few of his internal
organs doing that
[Laughter]
[Music]
wow
that is economical
[Music]
i didn't look like the average white
girl
i think that was me
never about to dance
[Music]
you go enjoy your time with that woman
[Music]
fun
we've been dancing for three hours it
took this long to get together
hey max
what i bought them
with my hands
where are we going
well the best day of your life now
you're an accomplice too you should have
a decent seat
hogwarts you okay
i've been looking out a window for 18
years dreaming
about what i might feel like when those
lights rise in the sky what if it's not
everything i dreamed it would be it will
be and what if it is
you get a hat you just chase that high
forever
[Music]
cool
[Music]
[Music]
light your own beacon home
i have something for you too i should
have given it to you before but i was
just scared i'm not scared anymore
you know what i mean you steal whatever
stuff you want oh he didn't even grab it
all those years
living in a blur
all that time
never truly seeing thing now she's here
shining in the sun wow what a beautiful
shot damn
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
everything okay huh
oh yes uh
yes of course
i just
gotta get paid man everything is fine
there's just something i have to take
care of okay
oh
you got a guilty walk my guy the crown
is all yours i'll miss you but i think
it's for the
best we heard you found something
something
oh
we want her
instead i was starting to think you ran
off with the crown and left me
wow they walk in a great line like we're
gonna use the fog to our advantage how
much do you think someone would pay to
stay young and healthy forever no
please
no
no
[Music]
the one time it gets caught in something
rapunzel mother are you all right
are you hurt
how did you i was so worried about you
dear so i followed you oh my let's go
let's go before they come to is he like
tied to it or something he's got to be
it's either like a dummy or else he's
yeah just like knocked out and tied to
it look
the crown rapunzel
no no no wait wait wait guys come on max
change of heart
[Music]
fly max fly
unlock your inner pegasus
let's get this over with ryder where are
we going community service now wash up
for dinner
i'm making hazelnut soup i really did
try rapunzel i tried to warn you what
was out there
all true
[Music]
my mother kidnapped me when i was a baby
i subconsciously painted the whole story
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
uncovered memory
rapunzel
rapunzel what's going on up there
yeah
i'm making a hair gun
close the door mom
let's take a seat i am the lost princess
aren't i did i mumble no mother did i
stutter [ __ ]
do you even hear yourself why would you
ask such a ridiculous question it was
you
it was all you
everything i did was to protect you
what did you do to him
that criminal is to be hanged for his
crimes for stealing all those apples
all of this is as it should be
no
you were wrong about the world break her
wrists
and i will never let you use my hair
again
what's this
open up one
two
three
hey use the frying pan
[Laughter]
gotta get me a good frying pan
head down head down arms in arms in
knees apart knees
why why do i need to keep my knees apart
oh my god oh my god
your genitals would be smashed crushed
into a fine powder
[Music]
dude i gotta get me a maximus
[Music]
oh my god it'd be great to own a horse
like max
strategist
this is your whole army right there
rapunzel let down your hair
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god he got stabbed he got real
stabbed for real oh look what you've
done rapunzel
we are going where no one will ever find
you again
now you've crossed the line pascal
i won't stop for every minute of the
rest of my life i will fight i will
never
stop trying to get away from you
if you let me save him
i will go with you
no
no rapunzel
i'll never run
oh for
por though just let me heal him and you
and i will be together
forever just like you want everything
will be the way it was i'll be your
battery mom i'm so sorry
everything is gonna be okay no rapunzel
i promise you have to trust me no come
on rapunzel wait
oh
[Music]
oh
what have you done
what have you done
yikes oh
bad news
[Music]
i like the symbolism
[Music]
that lizard murdered her yep look at me
look at me i'm right here don't go stay
with me eugene flower gleam and glow let
you power shine
make the clock reverse bring back what
once was rapunzel
dude why don't you just let her save you
first then cut her
wow we need to experiment on you
rapunzel
repository
what is your dna made yeah what can the
rest of your bodily faculties do one
teardrop did i ever tell you i've got a
thing for brunettes
i hate your natural haircut you are very
ugly to me until this moment
[Music]
all thanks to maximus maximus mvp
[Music]
i'm so happy
you get in here buddy you're part of the
family too
the kingdom rejoiced for the lost
princess had returned they pardoned me
for all my fever
thanks to maximus crime in the kingdom
disappeared almost overnight
[Music]
[Laughter]
as a general at last rapunzel was home
and she finally had a real family well
i'm pleased to tell you that after years
and years of asking and asking and
asking i finally said yes
and we're living happily ever after
yes we are
oh my god he was cupid all along dang
twist all right guys well before we go
into this
a word from storyblocks
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring
this video being the cinematic artisans
we obviously are we are always in search
of ways to make our videos look better
faster and most of all for cheap cheap
is good and if you're a content creator
or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position
it's tough to get your content looking
as good as it can be without breaking
the bank or burning yourself out in the
process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks
has to offer cheap is good do you feel
like this is their way of telling us
that the videos could be looking better
yes whether it's the credibility of an
exotic establishing shot the soothing
comfort of the perfect music bed or just
the satisfaction of increasing your
graphical capability storybox has an
incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles
transitions filters and effects and more
over a million assets royalty free and
available for personal and commercial
use with your membership sounds so
affordable this is quite affordable they
have multiple subscription levels to
suit your exact needs whether you're an
independent indie solo creator or a
whole team so if you want to learn more
head on down to our link in the
description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com
rejects now back to the video
all right john this is actually my fifth
time watching this one oh no knew it
beat by beat um
what did you think that was lovely i've
heard often this movie held up as one of
the best of the you know recent revival
of
disney animated musicals and whatnot and
uh i
got swept up and was quite delighted i
mean these are i
it always like catches me and it takes
me a second to orient because like they
they tend to like get off on the story
in a way where i'm like oh we're already
doing this
um but yeah like as it uh unfolds and as
it goes i thought it was quite charming
and i don't know the rapunzel
story like the back of my hand i know
like the very basics
um
so yeah it was it was cool to sort of be
in this place where i'm like okay i can
kind of see i think where they're kind
of embellishing and turning this into
more of a disney fairy tale but uh
but yeah i thought it was really
charming and delightful i like the voice
cast
you know yeah
manny moore and hugh jackman that's
right man you nailed it
for everyone listening to the podcast
john
hugh jackman thought it was an american
accented jackman
this american accent throws me
a
microphone
put it in put it inside your mouth
scraping against your beard
there we go there you go
yeah hugh jackman's american accent
throws me sometimes
but uh zachary levi props to him and i
wouldn't have guessed i wouldn't have
guessed for a movie like this um but
yeah it was quite charming there's a lot
of really lovely little visual
flourishes and i guess one thing i kept
noticing was
it's it's fascinating to me how far the
animation has come
because there are
absolutely aspects of this movie that
are beautiful and gorgeous to behold
even for the time because there are
certain things that have certainly
gotten better i feel like rock textures
now
are insane by comparison but they still
have such a
grip on color and uh and light
especially like with all those lanterns
and all that like foliage with the
shadows and sun bright sun shining
through illuminating all this greenery
illumination elimination
uh yeah i i thought uh from an animation
perspective it was quite lovely to
behold and uh
it's it's uh i
the mom
is
it's an interesting experience because
i'm like
you're supposed she's supposed to get on
your nerves
and she is in many ways the villain
and i thought it was interesting the way
that they orchestrated that
uh because she actually did get on my
nerves but not in a way that annoyed me
in spite of the movie
[Music]
what do you mean
i just want to strangle her the whole
time just let her know even when she's
being sweet i'm like oh you're
frustrating oh really i enjoyed her so
much i let no i really liked the
performance i i really liked
the mannerisms they animated her with
and the actress's uh performance in
there but also i was like uh like i'm
not
and i like it's weird
i'm not
holding it against the movie
because i don't think it's asking you to
be like nah she's good you know
uh no i set her up as the villain right
from the beginning but yeah but but you
know like seeing through rapunzel's
perspective early on before she knows
like i feel like you could play that
character in a way where she is
deceptively sweet
in a way that
in the moment you could see how rapunzel
could endear to her where you know uh
i don't think they did that so much here
uh
well i do think that they'd i would i
would
vehemently disagree okay strongly almost
aggressively disagree okay
i want to strangle you instead of her
i mean she was raised from birth though
yeah it's not like no i get came into
her oh my god fine i can't get a word in
this [ __ ] review sorry kids
children
came here
sorry guys
i'll uh
um
i'm sorry what were you saying
no it all made sense like yeah because
rapunzel's been raised by her so of
course she's not gonna have any reason
to suspect uh
the mannerisms being indicators of the
fact that she's not actually a
benevolent caring mother
they just read his quirks to her because
of course that's all she knows
then why are you questioning it it was
just an interesting flavor i wasn't
expecting what were you expecting
something really dark and heavy no
something where like the mom is like
really cloying and like overly like
lovely until we get the you know aside
moments where she's on her own and then
it's like haha i'm my evil motivations
blah blah blah
where uh i don't know they they kind of
struck an interesting nuance that i just
wasn't well they can't make her likeable
i know this is not a complaint
it would be very difficult to make you
know harder i don't want them to make
her like if the kids were watching this
in the theaters and they were like
i like her though she's sweet mommy
and she's been sweet up until the last
10 minutes of this movie oh my god that
would be so harsh
yeah i'm not just participating they got
to make her unlikable throughout
sure
john please
stop fighting yes yes of course sorry
i'll let it i'll let this go
this is embarrassing
you're so defensive over nothing that's
right
i'll let i'll loosen up please
in
all cases
oh yeah she was my she was my hero the
mom i was like i could learn a lot from
her
because if you can
control your kids like that you have
less
less annoying [ __ ] going on in movie
theaters you know what i mean that's
right just sit there and be like damn
why'd you bring your kid to this movie
oh shut up they're not interested in
being you can kill your kid
yes tilt them into
being obedient submissive
guilt them or scare them yeah
uh yeah
i i was
surprised by
it's because it's a 2010 movie and i
forget how much movies have changed yeah
you reminded me of the period of when
this came out
because
this movie is mainly like a it's very
i guess that's the thing what surprised
me the most is how remarkably
straightforward it is yeah it's it's
unbelievably straightforward in its
execution
and uh
yeah it it there's it's almost like
like so it's so simple in the way they
go about it yeah and it's just about
enjoying the
experience i think what helps
elevate it is the personalities of the
characters
that's the most refreshing aspect to it
because in terms of like how this movie
goes down it is
so straightforward and there's like no
fat
around anything no no no not at all it's
very lean
and um was this before frozen
i want to say i imagine it is because i
feel like this ushered in the the revamp
of the big
disney musical experience like it didn't
disappear but i feel like this was
definitely like the harbinger of a new
sort of renaissance that would then get
away from because my experience has been
kind of all over the place then with the
disney animated stuff
you know yeah
if this is the first so yeah it's very
straightforward film and that's not a
it's not a bad thing
and it's it's just like oh i you know
this movie is so praised and so loved
that
i was expecting something a little bit
more
perhaps
nuance throughout or something but i was
like oh this is really just a enjoyable
film yeah it's like it's really
economical and compact and i was
thinking about this during the movie
because there are there are disney
movies in this vein that do strike me
that way where i'm like okay this this
had to be kind of like probably the most
compact version of the events and script
possible partly because i'm sure there's
a lot more and different coordination
dealing with the animation and music and
whatnot but even the like like it has a
few songs
that's the other thing too is i was i
was taken aback by how straightforward
because like once you're
20 or so minutes in you're like oh no
like we're well into the actual plot not
just like setting up things uh but also
you know like there are a few songs that
are placed and for some reason it felt
like there were maybe less songs than
like your true the disney musical you
would expect but uh and at times it
feels like the songs are not even
like the complete track
yeah yeah it's interesting it's a
musical but in a in a way that felt a
little bit slightly different and i've
often heard people say
when talking about the various disney
musicals of late that this is one of
their favorites in terms of memorable
songs i really love the mother song
about mother knows best i think that's
really strong yeah it was very catchy
and um
you know of course you got mandy moore
on there so i imagine that was really
her scene has to be a crime that would
be to rob
we're gonna get somebody just got her to
do the the acting but not the singing
yeah
um i was like it's exactly revising but
the personalities of the characters i i
thought were just so charming
and and so likable and i was really
endeared to the main duo
of eugene and rapunzel i was i found
them really endearing and it got really
sweet and touching
like very very heartfelt in the last few
moments as well
uh
and i'm a little bit more used to the
storytelling of
today of
things that are like they go for like
the deeper messages or something more
nuanced to tell the kids and and here it
it didn't really do like
what's the message this will cut your
hair
oh good question
don't
don't listen to your overbearing mother
if she's evil if it turns out she's evil
maybe don't listen to her
find find your own
path in life don't don't let people keep
going
don't steal and uh don't steal look for
love find love like it's it's really
like just a kind of a classic disney
story but with a modern day
with a complete modern day overhaul
is is what it feel what it ultimately
felt like i guess there's that aspect of
because when when the hair is cut and
she's like oh no you know i don't have
any i'm not special anymore but then
this is the special was within her all
along
i think that's probably the yeah the
message
is uh it's not you don't need your
special hair to be a unique and
beautiful uh soul yeah it's okay to cry
it's okay to cry
it heals wounds like all the pokemon
at the end of pokemon the movie hey man
save ash save ash
tears that bring people back to life
all it took was one
i like the way they did that that struck
me i haven't
noticed something like that like that at
least comes to mind in an animated movie
lately where it's like that whole death
scene has this really washed out color
that contrasts the you know from the
rest of the entire movie which i thought
was a cool choice yeah
and uh yeah black and white
well almost it's like as desaturated as
you can be with while still having color
and then the mom just you know whizzing
in in front of your very eyes i guess i
guess i found myself
the the flavor of like the last 10
minutes is kind of what i was hoping was
sprinkled in a little bit more
throughout i did find myself craving a
little bit of that
because yeah this is before the time
that they seem to go out of their like i
remember the like frozen then frozen too
yeah like frozen two has this sort of
interestingly
shaped plot that isn't very
straightforward and frozen one had
the you know buzz of being really
subversive in terms of their formula
and so i feel like here you're you're
pre that yeah so this is like yeah this
is like them doing the classic but in a
in the most modern at the time you know
means possible yeah yeah yeah and i
appreciate that but yeah it was that
sort of thing where at first
because because yeah everybody holds it
up as like nah man that one's great i'm
like okay there's got to be something
like wildly unique about it's the
reputation
walking into it yeah that set kind of
this
precedent in our mind of
here's i'm expecting like that level of
emotional impact yeah yeah yeah
but but in a lot of ways like you know
like i don't want to be insulting to
anyone
well because it's not because i know how
much this movie means to people so
that's why i'm
semi mincing my words here is because of
the fact that i know this movie is so
near and dear to people and it's not
really a fear of being honest it's a
fear
of offending without
uh wanting to yeah so i'm just
intentionally don't get it twisted i'm
not disappointed and i didn't dislike it
i'm just i you know when people hail
something i feel like it creates i don't
know any expectation of greatness is
always going to kind of inspire a
different uh thing in each viewer
so yeah it takes a little to orient
yourself to
but at the end i wasn't like i don't
know what anyone's talking about you
know yeah i mean i liked it and i
thought it was very charming and and
very enjoyable entertaining but i i
can't say i i love this movie yeah yeah
i'm glad that i'm glad i saw it i would
happily watch it again i think i'll
think the most about maximus the horse
yeah oh he was great i thought the life
they brought to maximus was
i mean they have that classic disney
thing where turn them into a dog at one
point
like a dog pretty much that's what they
do with all these to even dreamworks any
animated property does it doggify hey
thor's hammer is a dog now dog or cat he
is a dog or catted that's the way you
make a an animal relatable this is make
it like everyone's most common domestic
pets
and they did at one point but when they
weren't doing that i was actually really
um i was really satisfied with the way
how much they made maximum super
expressive and
instead of just riding the line of him
being
you know
a horse that's a little bit more
expressive than your average horse they
just want to full extreme with him and
then he was like
soldier and a general
and i really and like i love that at the
end he was like training and so i think
that was really funny mm-hmm well it's
too a dis an example of one of these
movies that
ha you have pascal and you have maximus
but there aren't a whole lot of other
like
you know there's not the classic montage
of like oh the woodland creatures are
helping me spruce up the tower you know
like it's it seems like they are
the two creatures who are given yeah
anthropomorphic abilities
to the utmost degree and then pretty
much all the other animals seem normal
but i would like a really dark twisted
version of the story
one that would ruin the lives of
everyone i i think that would be very
enjoyable yeah instead of tangled call
it twisted twisted twisted i like it i
like it a lot mother going super dark
really manipulative locker and you
should be like carrie yes oh my god you
could do it though that's the problem is
that's actually a decent picture i'm
sure the if this mother is in the real
rapunzel story making what it is like
just make it a full-blown horror movie
and
maybe about trauma that she kills her
mom
because i'm like yeah you know i i feel
like uh uh uh
if they made this movie today
i'm not saying they would go all adult
but i think they might have pushed it a
bit more
especially in terms of the central
conflict uh because i thought that's
what they were setting up
like i do love you mom and i like every
day i do love you
um
it's it's not like cinderella being
you know
forced into this stepdaughter situation
you know
everyone's just terrible yeah yeah or
it's like yes you'll get away
and she's not going to miss you honestly
i feel like cinderella had a word since
like like cinderella
didn't have it worse but but uh though
her emotional response
to her mom and and where she lives is so
much worse like that is like overbearing
and so that feels like this is abusive
yeah yeah
and and they don't do that here with
rapunzel yeah and
and i and i so i was thinking
that they might go the route towards the
end when she does find out the truth of
feeling more conflicted
yeah about it because i'm like this is
my mom this is the woman who raised me
but it was like once she realized it it
it was like no you're bad i gotta get
out yeah
this fight that we just started having
well that's everything now
this just goes to support my
my rebellion and so i thought there
might have been a bit more of a layered
conflict
there and and i thought the movie was
building oh i thought the movie was
actually setting that up
yeah
yeah cause there's a lot you can there's
or even with the
evil mom you know like actually
learning to love her and stuff yeah like
or or maybe some kind of conflict yeah
of like i i have bonded i mean you know
i've raised you for eight 17-ish years
now and uh even though
i guess you yeah you could pitch it as
more of a s
uh sympathetic symbiosis where it's like
yeah i need her but maybe i'm gonna
bargain with myself and tell myself that
maybe this isn't messed up in some kind
of way
uh yeah i think it's because disney
movies nowadays i i feel like they're
not afraid to kind of
explore
like pain or some trauma loss you know
you know um right now parents got right
now they seem like they're obsessed with
generational drama yeah and and i and
and i think
that was the thing about this movie it
seemed like
that's
they wanted to make sure they stayed so
far away from that she is evil she is
the [ __ ] and every time she's
like ever so lighthearted and when she
finds out the truth there's no questions
asked
anytime she's alone she's going to
remind us that she's evil
and uh it's like the parents her
biological parents the king and queen
they they
you know they check in with them and i
like kind of the
quiet melancholy uh like the somber tone
with them like they don't really talk
you just see them looking sad and uh so
i like the way they were captured and um
yeah it seemed like they were like going
darker and
and i and i did expect that
because i thought the movie was setting
up but i'm like now i'm questioning it's
because of how they they're they're
willing to do that a little bit more now
nowadays they're willing to do that a
little bit more so is that why i was
expecting it to happen here now but what
i've expected the same thing back 12
years ago yeah that's a great question i
would be very curious i mean because two
because they evolved their movies now to
so that because because the fact they
weren't doing it back then yeah
and and it makes you wonder because i
you know i sit here and go okay they
probably made these choices because
i don't want to talk down but it feels
like a more like yeah it's super safe
yeah kids family movie choice we got to
make it really clear who the good guys
and the bad guys are so that
i mean
it's like we would like these nuances
and things and there's a lot of
interesting territory to explore there
although
you know for a young audience maybe
those things are a little more confusing
or a little more
you know maybe uh prone to flying over
people's heads or something children's
heads
um so i get that they
i don't know it seems like maybe they
wanted to keep those things clear and
have since let go
of those yeah um you know because like
you know like a frozen has that whole
thing where it's like you got the prince
and you you you're the whole time being
sold to think he's pretty great and then
it turns out oh dang he's not you know
and uh
i mean i don't think that would be hard
for kids to process but it is a bit of a
different thing you know
more of a nuance
true but still as a movie directly aim
for children
um it's
solid entertainment yeah
and um yeah i can see how especially for
the time it came out and of why it's
stood the test of time because was this
too i almost feel like this
i don't know the history of disney
uh
you know completely but i feel like
they've had definitely ebbs and flows in
the perceived quality and popularity of
their different uh especially like
musicals and princess movies and
flagships and stuff like that i feel
like when they start tapping into the
computer animation is when they were
like we're going super late
is this yeah and and is this one of the
cause because i'm trying to think of
when this came out in relation to
princess and the frog because that was
the last time they did like a hand-drawn
animated musical and i feel like that
was like the mid-2000s or something and
then this almost if i'm not mistaken
maybe that sort of kick off into i think
meet the robinsons was the kickoff
oh okay sure meet the robinsons it was
one of the earlier ones and people
forget about that one is that a muse
does their music it's not musical but it
is a it is like
like is that pixar no it's just disney
yeah disney animation yeah and then you
go one step further with a movie like
this and you go cause this is yeah it's
like it's it's princess movie it's
princess musical it's it's like animated
disney flagship you know type of story
and i feel like this kicked that back
off in the cg realm yeah so maybe two
people have that uh intense love because
it is kind of the beginning of a new
phase or a new
era age yeah
some kind of precious metal age
totes mcgoats yeah you know
you know
it's a delightful disney doing their
their thing
well guys
here we are
here we are
what'd you guys think about
tangled
leave your thoughts down below but
before we wrap this video up let's do a
patron of the day show
my god it's got to be lance door who
else would you want to get tangled up
with right oh my goodness who's the
person when you're caught
at the top of a building or a tower
who's going to go up there to rescue you
you want to see a little lance door at
the land store
getting that fire truck up there with
that extended ladder yeah you climbing
his way up there climb my hair lance
door
uh
i was just doing a straightforward fire
fire bit but you're a firefighter yeah
you're saying you're gonna let that
firefighter i don't know if you want a
firefighter to climb your you'd have to
bring climb the ladder
you gotta bring a whole bunch of [ __ ]
it's like a lot of extra pounds oh yeah
you got so much gear and i i regret this
immediately oh lance don't
take the ladder like he was saying i was
saying just i was just doing the
scenario being caught up in a tower and
someone's gonna rescue me yeah and it
should be lance i'm with you me putting
my hair down and
yeah
that's fair i i was more trying to meet
you part way like oh what if the
ladder's not tall enough to get to the
top of the tower so i got to like bridge
the rest of the gap with my was your
hair with your hair yeah and he would
help
so
and then your hair me out of the tower
under the weight
of all of his gear plus the strength
as compared to probably gwen stacy you
by accident he would absolutely like be
like i'll pull you out and then you pull
me out
my head would probably just come clean
off and then my body would just plummet
to the ground oh there's a horror movie
what if it like attaches to the ladder
and then he starts pulling you away and
and then lance accidentally removes your
scalp oh yeah oh you know i could come
back from that at least do you die from
a scalping if you just get a i think
it's
very likely you're going to if you could
get some disinfectant on there and just
seal that wound up real quick you know
put put yourself a gauze hat you know
would you be okay
lance if you have any experience with
scalping this is really dark
if any of you kids stuck around
for this lighthearted shout out oh my
god they've all heard some swear words
before but
yeah this was swear for free i don't
know
the shoutouts were free shout out to the
discussion is swear free but if they got
this far and now we've introduced the
concept of removing a person's content
it's just got some thematic elements and
some references to violence
rated pg-13
hey there was a little blood in this
movie
yeah for like samus
thanks lance love you buddy
[Music]
you